hi and welcome to episode number 31 of
the weekly Google club back from podcast
i am francisco and i'm here with Mark
mendall my colleague how are you doing
mark I'm doing well Francis are you
doing I'm pretty well I'm very happy
with the interview we're gonna be having
today with one of our colleagues working
here in the San Francisco office Eli
Bigsby yeah it's gonna be really
interesting discussion on tensorflow
we're gonna go quite deep on it I think
it's gonna be fun yeah you're gonna
learn about among all the things what is
why is it called tensorflow that I
didn't know actually so yeah yeah I
learned something today and after that
we're gonna be discussing we're going to
be talking about big data but not how to
process it but like how to upload like
really big data yeah we do when you have
lots of data that you want to give the
Google cloud yeah so we're gonna be
talking about the couple of options that
we have available for you if you have
like I don't know um terabytes petabytes
or whatever yeah lots and lots of data
but first we've got our cool thing of
the week yeah and it is very cool this
week yeah so we just literally just as
we were recording this announced the
Google cloud platform education grants
yep or for those less Australian grants
thank you this is this is a pretty cool
endeavor I'm very excited about it
basically currently it only applies to
the United States but we're hoping to
expand it internationally soon too soon
yes soon but basically yeah if you're
looking to use Google cloud platform in
your educational institution and you
want to have free cloud clerk cloud
credits say that three times quickly
free cloud credits for your students to
be able to use the resources at Google
Cloud we now meet the the ability to
apply for that yeah and it is very cool
because so far we've we've been doing it
for in some specific cases and actually
we have a link to the two blockers where
we announced the education program but
one of the links is actually cloud for
cancer and I was reading about it if
there was very cool it was basically
like an
network and if you don't know what any
other neural network is don't worry
we're gonna be talking about it in like
a minute yeah but basically a neural
network that allows doctors to upload
the properties of a melanoma and
detective is mulling or not so basically
is trying to provide a very good very
high quality information I think that
they mentioned they have like 99 dot
nine percent accuracy for doctors all
around the world which is pretty awesome
and it runs for free on App Engine
that's pretty cool yeah that's pretty
awesome there's a couple other things
that I quite liked about this one it's
not just a hey here's some stuff do with
it as you will there's also
documentation for students and teachers
that's provided so there's some there's
some extra resources you have to help to
teach this to the students as well as
that our faculty sponsors of Technology
focus groups such as women techmakers
Google developer groups etc etc are also
able to apply as well ya know it is
pretty awesome and for those that don't
have access to it yet don't forget that
if you want to give it a try there's
also the free trial program so you have
I think it's three months due in three
months you have 60 days three hundred
dollars i think was the last time I
looked at it yeah three hundred dollars
60 days which is not three months it is
two months yeah but yeah check it out
and if you're interested we'll have a
link on the show notes so you can apply
directly and maybe be one of the lucky
first ones to get our grants that'll be
great awesome well why don't we go have
a chat with eli and talk about
tensorflow cool let's dive with him
sounds good today we are joined by eli
Bixby he is happily agreed to grace us
with his presence how are you doing
today Eli I'm doing great Eli why don't
you tell us a little bit about who you
are and what you do here at Google great
so um I'm a developer programs engineer
at Google I work on Google cloud
platform and specifically the big data
and machine learning offerings cool so
what what is the developer prompts
engineer a like one sentence yeah that's
that's a hard task we could do an
episode of yeah one day
so we write a code to teach users how to
use the platform so this code may end up
in blog posts in tutorials and workshops
or it may end up on the website but well
so we have you here today because we
wanted to discuss a little bit about
tensorflow but before we start talking
about tensorflow for all the audience
that have never done any machine
learning what is like tensorflow i've
heard these neural networks what is an e
or network yeah so so tensorflow is is
mainly for neural networks a neural a
neural network in general is a you know
you can think of it sort of like as a
directed graph where the the nodes are
simply like arithmetic you know
activations of their inputs so you know
there are some nodes upstream they feed
into a downstream node and the node has
a single output based on the upstream
nodes and is it was sort of discovered a
long time ago you know like in the 70s
that you could use these and you could
use back propagation which is basically
says I want the top layer of nodes to
have this just certain or I want the the
output layer to have a certain output
when the top layer has a certain input
and you can you can use back propagation
to adjust the function that each node
operates on to line up with these
outputs and that you can model very
complex functions with many layers of
neural networks where did this idea come
from dunno na the history of how it sort
of came about um i'm not sure i think it
was actually originally sort of a
theoretical attempt to model like human
cognition which is why it's its neural
networks i I'm not sure that that is you
know part of its usage now but I think
that's where the name came from cool so
just to try to understand a bit better
when neural networks are basically at
the end of the day what you have is a
bunch of nodes and every note is like a
function where you get bunch of
parameters and
output yeah and and the nodes are
actually really a helpful extract
abstraction for us to think about it but
it's actually you know tensorflow is
named tensorflow because it's tensors
flowing along a graph and really you
think of it as the layers are single
entities that are that are you know
tensor transformations from one to the
next layer and and so often we we talk
about we talk about layers and the
activation function of a layer of the
tensor graph rather than individual
nodes cool so now we know what a-what
tensorflow comes from the name what
bodies why stands to flow a thing yeah
so um 10th or flow is the successor to
to google's previous machine learning
framework and and really the reason it's
open source is you know we believe that
there's going to be a lot of innovation
in machine learning and we think it's
important for for these tools to sort of
be standardized and for work to be
shared among the machine learning
community and so having a common
framework for expressing machine
learning algorithms is really important
so like previously you'd see papers and
you'd see people kind of informally
describe the algorithm that they were
writing about but now you can actually
publish the code and it's you know it's
another step towards reproducible
research it allows people to collaborate
more easily you know all the great
things we love about open source so you
touched on it a little bit when you
started talking about tensors flowing
through a graph but like we break that
down even further like what's a tensor
how does that work like this give you
sort of like a base level understanding
yeah so mathematicians are going to hate
me for this definition but a tensor is a
a multi-dimensional matrix so you think
of a vector is just a list of numbers
right so like an array in Python and a
matrix then is a list of lists of
numbers and so a tensor is you know a
vector is is a one-dimensional tensor a
matrix is a two-dimensional tensor and
then a matrix of vectors is a
three-dimensional tensor and you can you
can expand
that and you get this concept of shape
which is a vector that represents the
shape of a tensor and so for the users
who have used numpy before this should
be a very familiar concept it tensorflow
actually follows the exact same syntax
that numpy does for defining these
things and so how does that correlate
into like how we do machine learning
like why is that important yeah so so
it's really important in particular for
deep learning because a lot of these
algorithms can be thought of as a series
of tensor computations and and the
there's a lot of optimization you can
also do restricting the data that's
flowing along your graph two tensors so
if you compare it with something like a
patchy beam or spark where you there's
sort of arbitrary data flowing along
your computation graph and you can
define your own serialization and
deserialization tensorflow by contrast
is all in memory and and calls out to
you know very fast see implementations
of these tensor operations and and
obviously that allows you to make like
plug into like CUDA and use GPUs really
easily so the restricting it to tensors
gets us a lot of functionality
interesting so now that you actually
mentioned GPUs because I'm assuming that
Juve use are better suited for these
kind of computations but we also
announced this other thing TP use yeah
so the strength of GPUs actually ties a
lot into why we're seeing a resurgence
in neural networks is you know the
techniques have been around for a long
time and now we have this commodity
hardware that's just fantastic for
neural networks and and we're seeing
neural networks be extremely useful in
all of these applications and and so
we're seeing a huge growth and and we're
actually you know getting to the point
where it makes sense to actually have a
64 tensorflow so so that's what a TPU is
what's an ASIC an ASIC is a I think the
acronym is application specific
integrated chip so it's a it's a custom
piece of hardware that
and the optimization you're looking for
right because we have these big data
centers the applicant optimization
you're looking for is performance per
watt right so there they allow you to do
the operations that are common in
machine learning at a lower power and
that means you get a higher throughput
because you can run a lot more of them
for the same amount of electricity cool
so it sounds like tensorflow is kind of
a complicated and pretty complex
framework and that's that mean that to
get started with it I need to understand
what tensors and monads are no so so
that the actual goal is is that
developers can start writing machine
learning algorithms and start
incorporating machine learning easily
into their code and that's a that's a
huge goal of tensorflow so you know
tends to flow itself is a lot you can do
with it you know you can write custom
operations you know you can fiddle
around with the internals but we try to
provide a high level interface for
people who don't necessarily want to do
that and we're actually looking at
building more layers on top of
tensorflow to make it easier for
developers to get started with it so i
think i think it's publicly available
but but not you know i think it's like
whatever the open-source version of
alpha would be considered we have a
package called wide and deep which
provides a higher level of abstraction
on top of tensorflow that allows you to
say I have sparse features learn these
sparse features or like I have dense
features learn these dense features and
so it's very all you you know all you
really have to know about is what your
data looks like okay cool so how do I
know if tends to flow is good for me
like what are they use the typical use
cases where this the answer is that oh
yeah tends to flow yeah so um you know
we hope to expand it to a lot of
different machine learning applications
I think in particular if you have a
problem that's well suited to deep
learning tensorflow is is a great
solution for you again deep learning
algorithms you know they require a huge
amount of data to train
more so than many other machine learning
algorithms so you need to have that at
least somewhat available to you what's
like a good heuristic for a large amount
of data yeah um I think sort of like the
the ballpark lower levels maybe like a
hundred thousand okay labeled is common
for for example for text or yeah text or
image cool so you mentioned this label
does that mean that your data needs to
be labeled like and actually what does
it mean to be label yeah so do you need
that so there's we commonly break down
you know usage of deep learning into two
different parts we training and
inference and so training is your your
you know running this tensor flow graph
on your labeled data and using it to
generate the proper weights and then
inferences you have this unlabeled data
where you want to predict the label and
so you're giving that to the trained
tensor photograph and it's spinning out
you know a probability for the label so
when you say label was kind of like
alright so I've got a bunch of data
wherein I don't know pick an example
they have a bunch of emails and you need
to know if it's spam or not yeah that
works that's great so you know whether
it's spam and so you can feed that
through the system will I guess these
are families aren't and it could be like
a now I'm learning and then at the end
when you're doing your inference you can
hand it an email and it will tell you
whether or not it's spam yeah and I
guess some degree of certainty yeah
email is a perfect example because then
you have you have a bunch of users
essentially providing you with labels
you know they they click the report spam
button and bam you have another you have
another labeled piece of data and and
you know you did there's increasing
levels of sophistication but that's sort
of the basics is like I have this label
I want to predict the label of something
else so so maybe you have like a
confidence cut off and you're like oh my
my model is not very confident about
this piece of spam so I'm going to
surface it to the user yeah you were
mentioning something
which I thought it was very cool it was
the the one with private sub reddit yeah
so we gave a we gave a talk at oscon and
pike on where we you know made a little
example algorithm based on some some
colleagues work with text classification
and we used it to classify reddit post
titles as by subreddit and we got I
think a pretty good accuracy you know
not state-of-the-art but like I think it
was you know mid 90s and and yeah these
are these are topics that are very well
suited because there's large data sets
available so let's talk about that it's
that specific example how does it look
for developer to do that like i imagine
that have all the titles and what
sobriety did belong to mm-hmm what is
the next step yeah so there's going to
be there's going to be like a
pre-processing set up and you know we
frequently use apache beam to
pre-process our data and so then once
you have your data in sort of this nice
vector format you can go and grab you
know there's and try to adapt for your
use case one of the many open sources
you know many models already out there
so so frequently you'll you'll try to
figure out so what category does my
problem fit into it's okay it's a text
classification problem oh great
someone's already like written a text
classification model and then you'll you
know you'll try training that model on
your data with your pre process data and
then you'll do you know some testing
some validation and say okay this work
this didn't work let me tinker around
with the model a little bit until you
get sort of an accuracy you're happy
with let's sort of take a further step
back okay so you say modal what is like
what is that input and output look like
with the model yeah so together so
tensorflow graphs are defined with this
Python code so tensorflow is like a
Python package you right sort of
operations and you know an operation
will typically have arguments that our
previous operations you define so in
this way you're defining like a directed
graph so there's there's two parts as
the graph definition and then there's
the training step where you're running
through basically a loop saying okay
grab a batch of my training data you
know run it through the graph it'll
calculate you know gradients it'll
update the you know it'll update the
operations on each node like we were
talking about and then you know do that
until we're satisfied with whatever
accuracy we're getting whatever loss
we're getting you know whatever function
we've decided is is our metric and then
that will constitute a model and then we
there are also lots of sort of op seer
packages that we've open sourced so for
example tensorflow serving allows you to
serve models so do inference that's the
other half so you'll export a model
which is exporting these weights and
this graph to a file and then tensorflow
serving can load it for you and then
provide you an API a grp capi where you
can say you know you can call it with a
vector and it'll return back you know
the output vector that you would expect
maybe the labels so if i was taking say
like a reddit title and i'm going to
convert that into like a vector what
does that vector look like yeah so so
that's I talked a little bit about
before without explaining myself about
about sparse data and dense data so like
a reddit you know maybe a reddit title
is a list of vectors where each vector
is you know your entire vocabulary so
maybe like 40,000 words in the English
language or whatever and there's a one
somewhere in their corresponding to the
word you know a cat is a one and maybe
cat is like the thirty thousand two
hundred and fiftieth word so like the
30,000 250th index in your vector is one
and everything else is zeros so that's
sparse data frequently in you know in
deep learning will do embeddings so
we'll try to learn denser
representations of data because the
neural Nets tend to handle these denser
representations better
so like and this is this is something we
talked about in our workshop words
actually lend themselves very well to
this this dense embedding so you may
actually already have a model so there
may be if you look at so we we open
source syntax net for example which is a
piece of Google's natural language
processing written in tensorflow but
wasn't it cold parsing like Farsi yeah
so there's a subtle difference here we
open source two things we on open source
in technet which is the graph definition
okay and then we open sourced a trained
model so including the weights and the
volta all the trained bits called parse
emic parse face which was trained on you
know a subset of the data that we have
nice and so so if you look at syntax net
it's actually a bunch of like a bunch of
trained pieces a bunch of different
neural nets that feed into each other so
there's this the sense of composability
which brings me back to embedding so you
may have a model that somebody else has
already written for generating word
embeddings where you've you feed in your
you know you're one hot vector and it
gives you back a denser representation
of words so maybe the what you're
learning is a mapping from these word
embeddings to subreddit classification
and so so that's that's part of what we
like hope to spur by this this ecosystem
is like this this sense of composability
and other people taking their models and
using them as pieces of their own models
and then providing those models as
pieces for other people to use and and
and just sort of building this whole
ecosystem cool so we've been talking
about model models and that basically
you're going to be trimmed training some
nail net where you create that model and
then that model is a valuable piece of
information then again you can use how
big is a model oh man I think it varies
a huge amount I'm not even sure how well
I can give a ballpark i think it depends
a huge amount on your your the variables
like the size so like if we had a
vocabulary of 50 words
and we were doing or not a vocabulary 50
words if we were doing an embedding in
like a vector of 50 link that's going to
be a much smaller file than an embedding
of a vector of a hundred line hmm are we
talking gigawatts here IRA but I think
we can be talking gigabytes you know
smaller models i think maybe under that
but definitely I think probably not a
terabyte okay so okay so it's gonna be a
quiet on the order of gigabytes okay
okay so if I want to sit down and I'm
like all right this thing sounds super
cool since super interesting how would I
get started with 10 so floor where is it
where's a good place to start yeah so
tensorflow org has a bunch of great
tutorials that the brain team has
provided emne stizz kind of the hello
world of tensorflow so that's this
problem that's been around for for a
long time where you have handwritten
digits and you want to classify them you
know to the correct number and so I
think that's the you know that's sort of
the first place to get started and
there's a there's an amnesty for
beginners and there's an amnesty ml
experts so you know it'll walk you
through you know what is M nist why is
it important you know here's a little
bit of the math behind sort of the
state-of-the-art m nist algorithms if
you're a beginner and if not it'll be
just like here's tensorflow and here's
how it corresponds to the M nostalgia
them-- that you're familiar with very
cool also since you mentioned that
workshop that you gave at austin and
packin I was like three hours and it is
online could you recommend that as an
entry point to someone that has never
done tensorflow yeah yeah I mean we
tried to make it pretty accessible I
think even three hours it's kind of hard
to fit in a a comprehensive intro and so
I think it it's a little squashed but
but I certainly you should check that
out and and even even if it's just for
the resource slides we we have a lot of
resource slides in there to sort of get
you started on your own cool that sounds
very interesting we're kind of running
out of time is there anything else that
you Galacta mention before we finish not
off the top of my head that definitely
check out tensor floats it's worth worth
a look one last question actually
uh what is the best use case of
tensorflow the most fun oh you say just
answer fly you ever seen uh so I I love
DC games which is some crazy acronym but
generative adversarial network is the
last bit so it's actually two neural
nets that are competing against each
other one of them is trying to classify
the output of the first one and your
training data and the other one is
trying to generate from noise things
that look like your training data and so
your training this neural network to
generate you know to trick this other
neural network basing allow OMG and so
you generate it there's a bunch of
there's a bunch of hilarious pictures in
in the paper and in the github of like
generated bedrooms and they're they're
like uncanny valley bedrooms there
things that look almost like bedrooms
but there's something wrong about them
and there's there's generated there's
generated faces and they're like uncanny
valley faces it's like they're almost
almost faces okay we're gonna add a link
to that and yeah definitely check it out
so yeah very fun absolutely well Eli
thank you so much for joining us today
we really appreciate you taking the time
yeah thanks for having me thank you so
thank you to a life for such an
interesting conversation before we move
to the next topic I wanted to add a
couple of Corrections that he actually
gave as soon as we stopped recording one
of them we asked him how big data flow
models are and he said that probably
around gigabytes and turns out it's more
like megabytes and he said that the
problem is that he's not used to
counting down low anymore since he works
at Google can a humble brag but yeah
it's actually megabyte so you can
consider like sending them to your
mobile phone having them as part of your
app which is pretty cool and then
something that is not a correction but I
wanted to add anyway is he mentioned
about a he mention Apache beam which is
actually something you can run on Google
cloud platform Google Cloud dataflow and
also tensorflow you can run it or you'll
be able to run it soon because it's
limited preview for now on google cloud
ml sending for machine learning
obviously yes cool so so let's go with a
question of the week and I think it
comes from it cut it it you got the
question of the week I did get the
questionnaire week it was from some
people I was chatting with this week and
they were talking about how ok say you
have you know 10 terabytes 15 terabytes
20 terabytes of data so the lying around
maybe on an ass maybe on a hard drive
maybe running on prem something like
that and you want to move everything
over to Google cloud platform and you're
like like this is going to take me a
really long time to upload like if I
have to like do it over the wire so what
a way to you ain't called it into XML
and then yes no no so I mean there's one
option which is you can use yes util and
to start sending that file to through
the network and that's gonna take very
long time yeah weeks months yeah like
blonde long long time so instead of
doing that there's a couple options and
one of them was the one that you
mentioned right like yeah so we have a
couple of partners one of which is Iron
Mountain for us areas and the other one
is prime Fergus technologies for amia
and APAC pretty much is yeah you can
take a hard drive bundle it up stick it
on a courier like FedEx or us ups and
send it directly to them and then load
it up for you yes smart so so that is
actually yeah I think that Eli mentioned
that there is no higher look none no
wider been I know how do you said what
the band is bandwidth there's there you
go yeah there's a there's no connection
with higher bind with that the mail like
post mail you just send it and we
receive it well our partners receive it
and upload it and they appear directly
onto Google Cloud storage yeah so that
is probably one of the fastest options
but I want it toward one more which is
what if you really want to make this
very fast and all the time like what if
it's not that you're sending you have 10
terabytes and you have to send them once
but it's you keep on generating 10
terabytes per day and you want to send
that as soon as possible until you're on
tour
Google Cloud and there's a solution for
that it's what we call Google Cloud
interconnect and basically what you get
is rather than having like public public
internet connection from your data
center two hours you're gonna get a very
very very good quality connection I
think they use the term enterprise-grade
which I'm not really sure what that
means yeah but I'm assuming it's really
fast and it connects directly from your
data center to Google's network edge so
this would be if you had like a sort of
on prem cloud mix up type yeah do I
could imagine something like that were
for instance you doing something like
very very intense data like big data and
you're generating a huge amount of data
and you want to send it directly to be
quiet or something yeah and in that case
if you have such a huge amount of data
you need to send it somehow and maybe
sanding discs via mail is not good
enough yep so in that case you can go
through club interconnect the pricing
for it it's actually something that
depends on the cases so you need to
contact them I provider and II don't I
guess it depends how far away do you
live from a data center stuff like that
no that sounds really cool like maybe
you have requirements i mean you have to
be on prem for various things like your
app has to be there but you want to use
our big data tools and you want to send
that data through that sounds really
good um but now that's cool in and but
you know the the whole singing of hard
drives for UPS or fedex could be like
the one-time thing you do if you're
moving over to the cloud if you're if
you're on prem and you want to make that
shift as well yep cool uh well I think
we're pretty much done with the episode
yeah but I'm curious about what are you
gonna be up to next week or and after
that so I am saying in San Francisco for
the next week and a half but I will be
off to New York after that for a panel
at a play crafting event will be holding
in the New York offices cool so that
will be lots of fun and then after that
i'm hanging around in san francisco for
a little while so i think i'm pretty
good what are you up to so next week I'm
going to Los Angeles again this time I'm
flying
it should be faster yes yes and I'm
gonna be giving a talk loss I think the
name is Los Angeles Gophers made up its
the go made up in LA so basically it's
gonna be kind of my rehearsal for gopher
come unit then in the second week of
July I'll be a gopher come in denver
colorado that's pretty much it and after
that I think holidays are deserved it
sounds that sounds pretty good yeah well
friends desk thank you once more for
joining me for this weekly episode of
the podcast thank you very much mark
thank you very much do all that
listeners for paying attention once more
yeah and talk to you all next week see
you next week
you